abbiamo un'idea del terremoto come di
qualcosa più grande di noi un nemico
invincibile i suoi effetti una fatalità
il terremoto arriva e decide si prende
vite distrugge case ferisce
profondamente intere comunità oppure no
qualcuno si salva e allora è fortunato
questo scenario si ripete a ogni
terremoto ma è davvero inevitabile
c'entra la fortuna o questa fortuna ce
la possiamo costruire io come molti
credo che il nostro paese possa essere
messo in sicurezza il che significa che
nel caso di un terremoto magari si
danneggia ma non crolla
non perde vite umane e credo che per
realizzare questo progetto ci servono
essenzialmente una nuova consapevolezza
che si traduca in responsabilità
individuali e collettive e infine in
azioni decisive e determinanti inizierò
con raccontarvi di come io stessa mi sia
resa conto recentemente di avere un
grosso problema di consapevolezza sono
ingegnere strutturista lavoro presso
l'università di bergamo dove mi occupo
di metodi per la verifica di
vulnerabilità sismica degli edifici e di
tecniche per la messa in sicurezza come
accaduto che i terremoti dell'aquila
dell'emilia a fine settembre sono stata
chiamata assieme a molti colleghi a
contribuire alle verifiche di agibilità
a valle del terremoto di amatrice sono
stata assegnata al centro storico il
paese non c'era più un silenzio
spettrale così dissonante con tutto quel
caos e proprio mentre camminavo sopra i
resti di una delle vie rase al suolo
ho visto questo improvvisamente il vuoto
straordinario inaccettabile la
somiglianza con orso caramello
l'inseparabile amico peluche di mia
figlia bianca e lì
improvvisamente mi sono vista camminare
tre sopra macerie di edifici scarpe
seggio le giocattoli
impastate con macerie di edifici così
diverse dalle macerie neutre alle quali
sono abituate in laboratorio
ho visto persone popolari modelli
matematici coi quali simuliamo gli
effetti del terremoto
eccolo lì l'esito reale di una verifica
strutturale non soddisfatta da tecnico
sempre ritenuto la mia responsabilità in
qualche maniera limitata a comportamenti
strutturali da analizzare con cura a
tecniche per mettere sempre più in
sicurezza gli edifici ma davanti a
quella devastazione non bastava più
possibile che a ogni terremoto in italia
sia sempre la stessa storia si sa
tantissimo di terremoti e strutture ed è
sempre la stessa storia
e così mi sono chiesta ma come tecnico
come genitore come cittadino mi sto
facendo le giuste domande ci stiamo
facendo le domande giuste se prenotando
un hotel per le vacanze ci interessiamo
di il wellness wifi e non se la
struttura si o meno sismo resistenti
abbiamo fatto la domanda giusta o se
concentrati sugli aspetti pedagogici poi
scordiamo di chiedere se la scuola dei
nostri figli sia sismo resistenti
abbiamo fatto la domanda giusta
possibile che per l'acquisto di un
qualsiasi oggetto di uno smartphone
confrontiamo caratteristiche modelli
recensioni e poi per l'acquisto di una
casa per la quale alle volte ci si
indebita fino a 30 anni non chiediamo se
almeno sia sicura o quando installiamo
pannelli fotovoltaici cambiamo gli
infissi mettiamo rivestimenti isolanti
edifici vulnerabili e tutto crolla valle
di un terremoto abbiamo scordato
qualcosa di importante
non avvertiamo il rischio oppure ce ne
dimentichiamo
quindi è un problema essenzialmente
culturale
io non so non so se conoscete la
parabola dei pesci di wallace ci sono
questi due giovani pesci che nuotano
nell'acqua incontrano un pesce anziano
che nuota in senso contrario fa un cenno
di saluto
dice salve ragazzi come l'acqua due
pesci continuano a notare uno guarda
l'altro e chiede ma che diavolo el acqua
viviamo in uno dei paesi a più alto
rischio sismico d'europa questa è
l'acqua possiamo anche illuderci di
vivere in zone meno sismiche del paese
magari perché abbiamo scordato i
terremoti passati poi arriva il
terremoto in emilia un'area ritenuta
meno sismica e li crolla qualche
convinzione mappa di pericolosità
sismica alla mano però lo vediamo tutto
il paese sismico alcune zone molto più
di altre ma è tutto sismico e ancora
l'edificato l'edificato esistente in
particolare quello storico quello al
quale leghiamo più profondamente la
nostra identità culturale quello che fa
dell'italia l'italia è fortemente
vulnerabile l'ottanta per cento degli
edifici è stato costruito prima della
classificazione sismica del territorio e
si stima che grossa parte dell'edificato
necessiti di interventi di miglioramento
sismico e il terremoto ce lo conferma al
comune di amatrice sono stati dichiarati
inagibili 83 per cento degli edifici
questa è l'acqua e dunque è dunque il
paese sismico l'edificato vulnerabile e
se non facciamo qualcosa gli scenari
saranno quelli di amatrice dell'aquila
quelli di sempre nonostante le tecniche
per la messa di sicurezza in sicurezza
esistano e dunque e dunque dobbiamo
cambiare strada ma per cambiare strada
ci serve una consapevolezza nuova la
consapevolezza nuova si fonda sul porsi
nuove domande e quindi chiediamo ci vivo
lavoro frequento luoghi sicuri e poi e
poi facciamo qualcosa presto dappertutto
dobbiamo rendere resistente resiliente
il patrimonio esistente tutto non
qualche casa ma come boe avviamo una
rivoluzione culturale qui ci serve una
svolta
ci serve un radicale cambio di mentalità
di prospettiva
prima di metter mano agli edifici
dobbiamo agire sulle persone su di noi
se non cambia niente
quindi via liberiamoci
dall'atteggiamento pigro del fatalismo
diventiamo cittadini consapevoli
coinvolti a livello istituzionale molto
è stato fatto sisma bonus
classificazione sismica degli edifici
progetto casa italia per la prima volta
in italia è stato introdotto un piano
pluriennale per la riqualificazione
strutturale degli edifici
ma a che servono tutte queste misure
se poi nessuno le chiede e dunque
sensibilizziamoci a rischio o meglio
sensibilizziamoci alla prevenzione e al
fatto che le misure di mitigazione del
rischio sismico esistono ma soprattutto
che stano e chiederle come proprietari
di case rendiamoci conto che abbiamo
delle responsabilità
la casa è sì quel bene patrimoniale che
ci tramandiamo per generazioni ma è
sempre di più un bene funzionale del
quale dobbiamo prenderci cura per che
invecchia e va manutenuto non solo
ridecorato o ritinteggiato ancora anche
in fase d'acquisto facciamo acquisti
consapevoli c'è una responsabilità anche
lì non diamo per scontato che la casa
sia sicura valutiamo la sicurezza
strutturale e anche i costi per
ottenerla la sicurezza strutturale già
in fase d'acquisto del resto acquistare
oggi una casa non si cura una casa non
adeguata equivale a lanciarsi in
autostrada con un bolide anni 70 senza
poggiatesta cinture airbag abs evidente
nell'incidente non è certo ma perché
solo con l'auto siamo meno disposti a
correre il rischio non sarebbe utile un
promemoria come questo sapete di che si
tratta si tratta dei cartelli esposti
per legge in california c'è scritto
attenzione in caso di terremoto potreste
essere in pericolo
dentro fuori questi edifici
ritenete che porteresti i vostri figli
in edifici che gli espone sero li
acquistereste
per divulgare comunicare alimentare una
nuova cultura abbiamo bisogno di un
progetto educativo di formazione e
informazione a tutti i livelli e quindi
informiamoci e informiamo attraverso la
scuola ma anche attraverso tutte quelle
realtà che già operano sul territorio e
si occupano di sensibilizzazione al
rischio di divulgazione scientifica
amplifichiamo la loro voce
sostituiamo alla narrazione delle storie
del terremoto
il racconto di ciò che si può fare
coinvolgiamo coinvolgiamo i cittadini in
tutto questo è ancora anche la cultura
tecnica va condivisa e divulgata
abbiamo un patrimonio che è unico al
mondo ed ha bisogno di soluzioni
altrettanto uniche e ci sono
l'italia è all'avanguardia
nell'elaborazione nello sviluppo di
tecnologie per il recupero strutturale
il consolidamento così come lo
concepiamo oggi e scienza recente e ciò
che facciamo oggi in campo diagnostico e
tecnico era impensabile fino a pochi
anni fa e dunque è nostra responsabilità
dei tecnici dei ricercatori degli
operatori della filiera fare rete
condividere e divulgare la posta in
gioco è troppo alta ed è qualcosa che ci
riguarda non possiamo più delegare
aspettare che qualcuno dall'alto ci dica
che cosa dobbiamo fare
beh iniziamo noi iniziamo noi a metter
mano alla nostra casa e poi chiediamo
che sia fatto anche per gli edifici che
frequentiamo
e se tutti facessero così piano piano
arriveremo davvero mettere in sicurezza
al paese e cosa accadrebbe se
iniziassimo noi a chiedere la sicurezza
di case scuole luoghi di lavoro
beh cambierebbe tutto la prevenzione ce
la troveremo al primo posto dell'agenda
di governo
troveremo nuovi strumenti finanziari
legislativi per rendere sempre più
efficaci ed efficienti gli interventi si
finanzierebbe la ricerca e finalmente
l'importantissimo tema della
sostenibilità verrebbe declinato in
italia tenendo conto anche della seconda
sfida importante che è quella della
prevenzione sismica si farebbero assieme
comunque ce lo ricordava da bambini
diceva a meno che uno come te non ci
tenga molto
niente andrà meglio o sarà risolto ma
quando come possiamo iniziare a mettere
mano al patrimonio esistente a
contribuire a questo grande progetto di
mettere in sicurezza al paese
beh da subito trapano alla mano da
domani con l'aiuto di un tecnico
competente
partiamo da una nuova domanda
potete lasciare casa vostra in caso di
sisma dentro casa a costo zero rivediamo
all'arredo e assicuriamoci una via di
fuga
ci siamo immobili alle pareti le
librerie perché non ribaltino
ricordiamoci sui vetri rotti non si
cammina è anche un libro incastrato
sotto la porta ci impedisce ad aprirla
abbiamo una porta blindata potrebbe
disastri si blindarsi in casa e in quel
caso valutiamo via di fuga alternative
installiamo luce antipanico la luce è la
prima a mancare all'aquila tantissime
persone ci hanno raccontato di come si
siano salvate grazie a piccole luci
poste in punti chiave che hanno
illuminato le vie di fuga favorendo
l'uscita in qualche caso accelerandola
in altri trattenendolo in casa perché
perché il vano scala era crollato e poi
concentriamoci sulla struttura casa
vostra e sicura lo sapete veramente da
chiediamo a un tecnico competente
chiediamo la verifica di vulnerabilità
sismica dell'edificio
ci serve un bravo ingegnere che proprio
come un bravo medico valuti sintomi
prescriva le analisi più adeguate
elabora i risultati e infine pervenga
una diagnosi
questa è una fase iniziale è
imprescindibile
e quanto più sarà curata quanto più
dettagliata sarà la diagnosi e quanto
più specifici e mirati gli interventi
individuati come necessari e attenzione
qualora dovessimo intervenire non è
detto che l'intervento sia costoso
esistono più approcci possiamo adeguare
sismicamente la casa
il che significa che la nostra casa avrà
le prestazioni di un edificio di nuova
costruzione
ma se questo intervento
forse eccessivamente oneroso possiamo
decidere di concentrarci dapprima
sull'intervento minimo seguiamo una
politica di piccoli passi
prima facciamo gli interventi prioritari
sono quegli interventi mirati che
risolvono le vulnerabilità più grandi e
quindi di fatto riducono moltissimo il
rischio di crollo e tutelano le persone
e il bene contenuto poi potremo
pianificare gli interventi da eseguire
successivamente per pervenire a livelli
di sicurezza sempre maggiori nel tempo
potremo agganciare questi interventi a
quelli nella pianificazione della
manutenzione programmata in quell'ottica
che l'edificio invecchia e va manutenuto
ancora potremmo addirittura decidere di
agganciare questi interventi ha gli
interventi di miglioramento energetico
in questo modo combinando questi due
interventi noi sfruttiamo il vantaggio
che abbiamo della riduzione dei costi in
bolletta è però abbiamo ci pagano
intervento strutturale abbiamo un
edificio più sicuro del resto l'abbiamo
visto non è proprio green quell'edificio
super performante energeticamente che
poi crolla al prossimo terremoto è un
approccio questo dei piccoli passi che
molto interessante perché perché siccome
ci impegna un poco meno subito a livello
economico ci concede di continuare a
prenderci cura anche d'altro perché non
è che dobbiamo vivere di stenti dentro
un bunker anti sismico
sempre parlando di interventi integrati
energetico strutturale facciamo degli
esempi al posto di di una copertura
ventilata tradizionale chiediamo una
copertura ventilata ma anche antisismica
del resto si tratta di accostare allo
strato isolante uno strato che
organizzato strutturalmente faccia da
coperchio all'edificio leghi insieme le
pareti e lo rinforza enormemente nei
confronti delle sollecitazioni sismiche
ed è allo stesso modo al posto di un
cappotto tradizionale isolante possiamo
chiedere che sia installato anche uno
strato che renda l'edificio più sicuro
nel combinare questi due effetti c'è
questi due interventi noi riduciamo il
costo complessivo dell'intervento perché
sfruttiamo la cena
regia del cantiere unico questi
interventi integrati possono essere poi
spinti molto di più fino a arrivare a
diventare tecniche di riqualificazione
olistica dell'edificio nel suo complesso
e quindi risolvono in un sol colpo il
problema sismico il problema energetico
il problema della funzionalita
dell'edificio e consentono anche di
ridisegnare l'aspetto dell'edificio
stesso
queste tecniche delle quali ci stiamo
occupando presso le università di
bergamo e brescia si ispirano alle
tecniche o meglio alle soluzioni che già
vengono usate in francia in germania per
la riqualificazione del costruito
ma qui le re ingegnerizzato per tener
conto dell'ulteriore sfida che è quella
sismica che in altri paesi europei
ovviamente non esiste si tratta di
realizzare un secondo involucro fuori
dall'edificio si lavora solo
dall'esterno non si riducano le persone
e all'interno di questo involucro
verranno alloggiati i presidi per la
messa in sicurezza strutturale tutte le
tecnologie per rendere l'edificio
performanti a livello energetico questo
involucro in funzione dei vincoli
urbanistici potrà essere aderente alla
struttura oppure posto una certa
distanza in quel caso riusciamo a
realizzare nuovi spazi abitativi balconi
lodge serre solari
oppure possiamo prenderli involucro ed
estenderlo in altezza e allora
realizziamo un sopralzo la cui vendita
magari in parte compensa al costo della
riqualificazione replicato a livello di
quartiere
questo intervento ha chiaramente la
potenzialità di favorire il processo di
rigenerazione urbana delle periferie che
diventano più vivibili più sostenibili a
livello ambientale ed anche più sicure
dove arriverà il prossimo terremoto
col terremoto la fortuna non basta ma
noi possiamo fare qualcosa
noi possiamo rendere sicure le nostre
case le nostre città e questo è un altro
modo concreto e bellissimo di prenderci
cura di noi dei nostri figli della
società ma anche della memoria e della
storia
ereditiamo custodiamo scriviamo e poi
tramandiamo alle future generazioni
sta a noi se ci prendiamo un sabato
pomeriggio per fissare i mobili alle
pareti e se contattiamo un tecnico per
cercare di capire come sta messa a casa
nostra
avremmo già decisamente cambiato strada
quella di prima ci sembrerà vecchia è
lontanissima in un istante agiamo subito
sarà un percorso lungo ci coinvolgerà
tutti e anche più generazioni ma ne
saremo contenti domani davanti agli
occhi allibiti dei nostri nipoti che ci
chiederanno
no veramente non le case cadevano col
terremoto grazie
[Applauso]